donc cette crise loin de se résorber
elle ne fait que s'amplifier de jour en
jour on en voit de plus en plus
d'immigrants on n'a qu'à regarder les
chiffres et ça donne le vertige céline
224 1000 réfugiés qui sont arrivés sur
le territoire de l'union européenne dans
les sept premiers mois de l'année et ça
il ya des pays qui en accueille encore
bien plus la grèce par exemple cette
fois plus que l'année dernière dans les
premiers mois de cette année 124 mille
réfugiés sont arrivés en grèce
seulement dans le mois de juillet
cinquante mille réfugiés alors
évidemment c'est énorme et l'europe vous
vous souvenez a essayé de répartir ces
réfugiés de façon équitable de façon
humanitaire aussi parce qu'il ya des
pays qui en accueille presque pas et
bien lors pas failli dans cette
tentative de les répartir
parce qu'il ya des pays qui s'y sont
opposés comme la pologne les pays baltes
l'autriche et la l'espagne se sont
opposés à ça donc c'est toujours les
mêmes pays se retrouve avec le plus de
réfugiés entre autres à cause de leur
situation géographique comme l'italie
vous vous souvenez lampedusa et
maintenant la grèce mais solide le cos
la semaine dernière on a vu une
débordement de sacrés et maintenance et
en macédoine qui a une crise on a
décrété l'état d'urgence
oui la macédoine un tout petit pays de
deux millions d'habitants céline et bien
la macédoine se trouve aujourd'hui en
plein milieu du chemin qu'emprunte le
gros de réfugiés vers le territoire
européen
alors si les réfugiés qui viennent de
l'irak de la syrie de l'organiste ans
qui fuient la guerre passe par la
turquie de la turquie ils vont vers la
grèce entre autres l'île de kos qu'on a
vu la semaine dernière et de là ils vont
vers le nord vers la frontière avec la
macédoine souvent aidés par les
autorités grecques alors la macédoine a
enregistré plus de quarante et un mille
réfugiés sur sa frontière sud
dans les deux derniers mois ensuite il
passe vers la serbie ça va assez bien
jusqu'en hongrie est là et la hongrie
c'est déjà le territoire de l'union
européenne
mais l'on grille en hongrie est en train
de construire une barrière de 175 km
pour empêcher ces immigrants d'arrivée
alors évidemment
gens sont au courant entre la carrière
et la barrière est en train de se
construire et il se dépêche pour se
rendre là d'où le l'afflux de réfugiés
ce précisément au mois de juillet alors
l'europe est en train de construire des
barrières un peu partout parce que celle
là va s'ajouter à celles qui existent
déjà entre la grèce et la turquie entre
la bulgarie et la turquie et autour des
enclaves espagnoles de ceuta et melilla
au nord du maroc
la lan l'europe s'entoure de barrières
s'entoure de murs mais elle n'arrive pas
à résoudre ce problème de réfugiés que
la chancelière allemande angela merkel a
appelé le plus grave problème que
l'europe aura à traverser dans les
prochains mois bien plus graves encore
que la crise de l'euro
et rappelons que l'allemagne l aurar
accueillir cette année huit cent mille
réfugiés qui a plus que l'année dernière
où est ce qu'on verra ce que toutes ces
barrières randonnée parce que dans le
reportage jean-françois c'était assez
clair que les gens seraient tous merci
beaucoup alexandra